[Musique]
internet et le web ont été conçus pour
connecter les ordinateurs et des pages
de documents entre eux mais très vite
les hommes s'y sont précipités pour 6
interconnecté eux mêmes pour faire des
réseaux les réseaux sociaux où j'ai
plein d'amis plein d'amis virtuels
facebook linkedin twitter instagram snap
chat on a construit le village global
dans lequel je reste connecté avec ma
communautés d'un bout à l'autre de la
terre dans ce village global le rêve de
la relation à l'autre il est parfait
j'ai plein d'amis je suis connue
j'existe mes posts sont repris retweeter
partager aimé et je pèse ma popularité
au nombre de mes laïque mes amis aussi
partage du contenu qui m'intéresse les
livres les films qu'ils ont vu les
spectacles les expositions auxquelles
ils ont été les articles de presse les
blagues et ça tombe bien j'aime bien ce
que partagent mes amis et pour nous
aider à ça les réseaux sociaux ont conçu
les algorithmes ses algorithmes de
recommandations qui vont prendre ce
contenu populaire pour ma communauté
le mettre en valeur et de sorte qu'avec
ce filtrage collaboratif comme on dit en
fait on va voir au sein de la communauté
les mêmes choses les mêmes contenus les
mêmes livres les mêmes films à la même
exposition va penser un petit peu la
même manière voir le monde d'une
certaine manière les algorithmes ont été
plus loin parce qu'ils m'ont suggéré de
me connecter avec des personnes
personnes qui ont fait les mêmes écoles
que moi la même université qui ont
travaillé dans les mêmes entreprises et
même ville le même secteur industriel on
a des amis en commun au polo les mêmes
influenceurs et dans cette communauté
c'est bien parce que se renforcent
quelque part on ait l'impression qu'on
pense tous un petit peu la même manière
ce qui est logique
les valeurs sont stables ces
bienveillant les robots journalistes
écrivent des articles pour nous qui sont
ciblés et puis c'est rassurant d'être
dans cet espace parce que le monde lui
il est un peu violent n'est ce pas un
peu agressif individualiste comme ça
égoïste on est une violence sociale
économique et des laissés pour compte
le monde fait peur puis le relativisme
qui existe
une vérité chacun a sa propre vérité
tout se vaut alors qu'à l'intérieur de
ma communauté et de moments de virtuel
voilà on est bien mieux pour tous un peu
de la même manière au plus on se
regroupe entre soi dans ces petites
communautés là au plus ce repli
identitaire au plus on se sent bien
entre nous au plus les communautés
divergent
elle s'éloigne elle se clive on comprend
pas trop les autres communautés elles
voient pas le même monde que moi elle me
paraît étrange bizarre on les catégorise
on les étiquettes et puis très vite on
voit un petit peu dans les tweet clash
ou les commentaires des insultes qui
fusent
simplement parce que ces communautés
quand elles se sont repliées bien sûr
elles mêmes elles ne comprennent plus
l'autre n'arrive plus à dialoguer et on
comprend pas pourquoi on n'arrive pas à
dialoguer et ça se termine souvent quand
même avec une espèce de déferlement de
haine ou de choses
est ce que les réseaux sociaux seraient
devenus antisociaux et est ce que le
cauchemar de vivre ensemble demain ce
serait pas le vivre ensemble avec des
clones avec des gens qui me ressemblent
l'homme se construit dans la relation à
l'autre dans l'altérité dans l'autre qui
est très différent de moi parce que seul
l'autre va me bousculer va me descend
très va changer mon point de vue sur le
monde va me bousculer un petit peu me
déséquilibré et puis l'autre il va
résister à ma volonté
d'autant plus s'il est présent
physiquement devant moi c'est facile de
couper une conversation par un clic de
fermer une fenêtre de fermer son
ordinateur ou de débrancher l'autre de
ses amis quand il est virtuel c'est plus
difficile quand il est présent en face
de moi alors on imagine utiliser les
technologies des réseaux sociaux pour
faire se rencontrer des gens très
différents pour faire se rencontrer des
gens physiquement utiliser les
technologies des réseaux sociaux les
détourner une certaine manière pour
inventer une technologie positive dans
laquelle on pourrait se rencontrer dans
le vrai monde et rencontrer des gens qui
ne se côtoient pas on rêve avec
entourage d'avoir deux mondes qui ne se
connaissent pas très éloignés l'un de
l'autre mais qui partagent le même
trottoir sur les réseaux sociaux on m'a
fait croire que j'étais plus proche de
steve inquiète à san francisco que de
raul qui est sdf en bas de chez moi et
que je croise tous les jours
vous savez ces personnes sdf on les voit
quand on va travailler tous les jours
elles sont là au même endroit on est un
peu gêné on sait pas trop comment
l'aborder on sait pas trop quoi lui dire
alors on pressent le pas on détourne le
regard on n'ose pas trop s'arrêter et en
même temps on aimerait bien faire
quelque chose non c'est pas quoi elles l
ont pas ce village global
elles ont pas cette communauté elles
n'ont pas ce réseau
cyril qui est un ancien maître d'hôtel
qui est actuellement sdf me dis je vois
pas ces 3000 personnes tous les jours
devant moi il y en a deux qui me disent
bonjour ou pire au québec tu as la rue
qui me dit ma la solitude ça tue un
bonjour ça vaut 100 sandwich laurent qui
dort sous sa tente
on est invisible pour les gens me dit il
on ne nous voit pas on ne nous regarde
pas est ce qu'on pourrait imaginer des
entourages bienveillant qui serait
constitué par des riverains des
personnes qui feraient des actions
concrètes dans la vraie vie avec ces
personnes sdf qu'on croise tous les
jours des actions simples on fait un
cinéma ensemble on prend un café on lui
apprend le français s'il est pas
français
on est dans une démarche de papier ont
fait un truc ensemble alors on a créé un
réseau social sur téléphone mobile qui
s'appelle entourage
c'est le réseau des gens qui n'ont pas
de réseau et le réseau des gens qui
n'ont pas de réseau quelque part ça me
permet de créer des entourages autour de
moi d'identifier où ils se trouvent de
les rejoindre
peut-être de les créer moi-même et de
faire des actions d'aller se rencontrer
dans la vraie vie
le but ici bien sûr c'est la rencontre
la rencontre avec l'autre qui est très
différent cette fameuse rencontre dont
on parlait tout à l'heure
cette rencontre elle me fait grandir il
ya plein de raisons pour laquelle cette
renconte elle m'a fait grandir
je vais vous en donner juste 3 mai en a
beaucoup d'autres en fait c'est une
expérience à vivre parce que seul canton
a fait cette expérience de la rencontre
avec l'autre qui je crois est différent
de moi c'est seule cette expérience qui
parle la première raison c'est que c'est
l'instant présent en fait on vit tous
très peu dans l'instant présent on est
toujours fourré dans le passé dans nos
souvenirs à nous remémorer des choses ou
dans l'avenir en train d'imaginer des
nouveaux projets en fait les personnes
sdf qui sont là dans la rue leurs passes
il est pas très glorieux les faits de
violence il est quelque chose qu elles
ont plutôt envie d'oublier et le futur
le voit pas il est bouché et elle vivre
l'instant présent elle tout le temps
elles sont dans la survie du jour qu'est
ce que je vais manger aujourd'hui où je
vais dormir comment je vais me protéger
et quand vous créez un lien avec elle
elle vous ramène instantanément dans cet
instant présent que vous ne connaissez
pas et ça c'est un sursaut de vie c'est
un surcroît de vie parce que à partir
mon se reconnecte au présent on vit plus
un deuxième exemple que l'instant
présent qui est le masque social quand
on interagit entre nous on interagit à
travers de nos masques
là je suis ingénieur je suis banquier je
suis pharmacien
évidemment on parle de masques hamas qu
on se cache derrière ça va pas montrer
nos fragilités qui on est vraiment ces
personnes sdf quand vous allez les voir
avec votre masque il sert à rien ce
masque vous pouvez le laisser à côté
elles sont là livré à nu et quelque part
laissé tomber son masque sa fille du
bien est ce qu'on se transforme on est
beaucoup plus humain on est soit si une
rencontre d'hommes
dernier exemple que je voudrais vous
donner mais y en a beaucoup d'autres il
faut faire cette expérience c'est la
pauvreté c'est on a peur de discuter
avec ces personnes parce qu'on a peur de
cette pauvreté on a peur de notre propre
pauvreté d'une certaine manière c'est
quoi la pauvreté la pauvreté c'est être
entièrement dépendant des autres
en tout je dépends des autres pour
manger je vais dépendre des autres pour
dormir je vais dépendre des autres pour
me loger
je vais prendre une décision dans une
assistante sociale le risque c'est celui
qui à tous qui se sécurise par lui-même
qui croient qu'il n'a pas besoin des
autres
il se sécurise avec son argent avec son
diplôme avec son réseau de relations
avec toutes ces choses alors qu'en fait
évidemment on est tous pauvres
ontologiquement l'homme a besoin des
autres on est dépendants les uns des
autres de retoucher cette dépendance
lorsqu'on va à la rencontre de la
personne la plus pauvre
ça me fait devenir plus humains je vous
rappelle ce poète john donne qui disait
nul homme est une île que je vous
conseille de relire
alors voilà je vais conclure par un mot
qui est un mot qui a été oublié
discours public dans meilleur des cas
qui est un mois important qui est
tellement important qu'on l'a inscrit
dans la pierre sur le frontisme de nos
mairies et de nos écoles qui est le mot
fraternité la relation à l'autre
elle fonde la dignité humaine la
bienveillance même la douceur manque
cruellement aujourd'hui donc on va faire
en sorte que ce rêve devienne une
réalité de changer le monde
je vous invite à rejoindre ce mouvement
je vous invite à devenir acteurs de ce
changement de société vers quelque chose
de plus humain
je vous invite à rejoindre ce réseau
concret entourage c'est d'un réseau de
chaleur humaine
je vous invite à oser la fraternité
merci
[Applaudissements]